the world needs a new Iron Man chances
are pretty good that you've already seen
Avengers endgame and don't need the
spoiler warning but as you don't know
Tony Stark doesn't make it out of
endgame alive since so much of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has been built
around Stark on his armor clad alter-ego
his absence leaves a pretty big vacuum
but will it stay that way forever
maybe maybe not here's how Iron Man just
might return to the MCU in one form or
another one of the best things about
having a hero whose powers come from a
suit of armor is that almost anyone can
wear it assuming they're the kind of
person who doesn't mind flying around
with rocket boots and shooting bad guys
with repulsor rays if that's the case
then there's no better candidate for the
new Iron Man than Colonel Jim Rhodes who
already has plenty of experience in the
suit I'm gonna have to hang on to your
suit for a minute okay not okay not okay
with that wasn't a question that's what
makes Rhodey the obvious choice though
in the comics he's been better known as
war machine for decades but Rody's first
major story came when he took over the
identity of Iron Man more Tony was
struggling with alcoholism his tenure as
the armored Avenger lasted for four
years and even saw him as the version of
Iron Man who went off to fight in the
Secret Wars event Brody has the added
bonus of being a known quantity among
MCU fans Don Cheadle might have replaced
Terrence Howard with the second movie in
the Iron Man franchise but the character
has been around since the first Iron Man
film then again that might be a
detriment Cheadle's thus a major Sony
and while they obviously didn't keep him
from the epic superhero action in
endgame filmmakers might be looking for
someone younger going forward endgame
paid off plenty of points and lived up
to his promise of being the end of an
era
but the MCU shows no sign of slowing
down anytime soon so it makes sense that
endgame would also lay down a little
foreshadowing of its own if that's the
case then there might be a good reason
why Morgan Stark
Tony's five-year-old daughter is
introduced to us wearing one of Tony's
helmets and the toy repulsor and why a
huge chunk of the movie is devoted to
Tony reconciling with his own father
from helping found shield to help him
found the Avengers and pepper showing up
as rescue super heroism is a family
business for the Starks there's no
reason why Morgan couldn't eventually
carry on that legacy the obvious problem
there is that Morgan Stark is 5 years
old it's also completely in charted
territory
unlike Rhodey who's
well known quantity as Iron Man Tony
Stark has never had a kid in the comics
there is an existing Morgan Stark on the
page but he's Tony's nefarious cousin
who constantly attempts to take over its
business the MCU wants to get really
weird that there's one very unlikely
character who could take up the armor as
he all-new Iron Man Peter Parker
spider-man is after all one of Marvel's
most popular characters and with into
the spider versus critical acclaim he's
one of the only superheroes who can
carry two simultaneous film franchises
but for now at least have nothing to do
with each other in fact the latest
trailer for spider-man far from home
heavily implies that Peter is actually
thinking along these lines
the world needs Next Iron Man so yeah it
could definitely happen but it's almost
certain that it won't lending his role
with Iron Man's wouldn't really do
either of those brands any favors and
would probably dilute the elements that
make each of them work on their own
still there's a level where it would
actually make sense
from the moment he stepped onto screen
in Captain America Civil War Tonia's
mentor Pizza looking to avoid making the
same mistake his father made when it
came to dealing with a teenage super
genius all right
there's an almost familial connection
here which we see an endgame when the
only people who really get to mourn for
Tony on the battlefield a pizza Parker
and Pepper Potts Tony has even provided
spider-man with his equipment giving him
the high-tech version of his familiar
suit that he wears in homecoming and the
iron spider armor that we see him
wearing an infinity war and end game
it's a relationship that they've never
really had in the comics and if he was
any other character Peter would be the
obvious choice to take over as it stands
we're definitely getting a further
examination of that mentoring
relationship but it's far more likely to
end with spider-man deciding to strike
out on his own
if the MCU really wants to move forward
and put a younger character into the
armor they don't need to go for
something as wild as Peter Parker Iron
Man the comics have served up a
ready-made replacement in the form of
reread Williams better known as Iron
Heart introduced in 2016 weary is a
teenage genius from Chicago who
reverse-engineered stark technology and
built her own suit of Iron Man armor
since Tony Stark was dead at the time
and is often the case in comics he got
better she wound up fighting crime
assisted by an AI version of Tony
eventually after a meeting with Pepper
she wound up creating her own suit from
scratch and taking the identity of iron
hearts as far as replacements go should
definitely be an interesting one but the
fact that she has an established super
heroic identity that's already appeared
in cartoons would seem to make that
unlikely still there's one really cool
connection to the roots of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
back in 2008 Tony Stark built his first
suit of Iron Man armor in a cave we
rebuilt hers in the garage echoing those
roots in a different form it would be a
nice way to go forward
maybe Marvel doesn't actually want to
replace Tony Stark as Iron Man
maybe they want to bring him back but
also make sure that they don't undermine
the sacrifices he made to defeat Thanos
if so there's one way that they can have
their armor plated cake and eat it too
they could give us the film version of
Team Tony the comics killed off Tony
Stark in 1996 after revealing it was
secretly a villain and attempted to
attract new readers by replacing him
with a teenage version of Tony from
another dimension
like the original Tony he had to wear
the armor to keep his heart beating but
did so as a cool 90's youth who didn't
have a moustache he also didn't have
much success in the whole get people to
read this comic thing and just killed
off the heroic sacrifice 10 months later
quickly becoming one of those
we had comic things that we just don't
talk about much still it's been 22 years
and that's enough time to give this idea
another shot by casting a young CW star
as the all-new Tony Stark we even have
more than a few hints that the MCU might
be introducing a fuller multiverse as of
spider-man far from home giving him or
any other alternate Tony the perfect
opportunity to jump into the MCU is team
Tony going to happen probably not but
that's exactly what we would have said
if you told us 10 years ago that Rocket
Raccoon crossbones and mbaku were going
to be in the same movie and that it was
going to be one of the biggest
blockbusters of all time time makes
fools of us all there's another
alternate version of Iron Man who seems
like he's begging for a comeback are no
Stark the Iron Man of 2020 he was
introduced in 1984 when 2020 still
seemed like the far-off future the basic
idea is that he was a younger cousin of
Tony Stark's who used a scary-looking
version of the Iron Man suit to act as a
mercenary
thanks for the magic of time travel
Ironman 2020 wound up fighting
spider-man in 1986 and I am man in 1990
in what was a surprisingly uneventful
career as a super villain with 20/20 on
the horizon it might not surprise you to
learn that Marvel has been laying the
seeds for Arno to make a return in the
comic books most recently it turned out
that Tony was actually adopted and that
Howard a Maria Starks first child Arno
had been the subject of genetic
experimentation by an alien robots which
caused them to adopt Tony it's
complicated Arno eventually made his
return as a relatively heroic character
who teamed up with the Tony and is
currently floating around the marvel
universe presumably waiting to live up
to his name obviously that's some
complicated stuff even by Marvel
standards but hey the opportunity to use
Iron Man 2020 and 2021 s' if Tony Stark
himself is going to make a comeback then
there's an easy way to pull it off
without cheapening his death in endgame
just have Tony return is not official
intelligence this has been done before
in the comics most recently the
aforementioned AI Tony that helped VV
Williams build our armor and serve as
our onboard computer of course in the
comics living artificial intelligence
characters are a dime a dozen but the
MCU isn't far off itself Friday and
Karen the onboard AI for Spider Man
start design suits both have distinct
personalities and Java
the Iron Man suits originally I was even
able to evolve into a full-on superhero
in age of Ultron when it became the
vision this all depends on how truly
done with the role Robert Downey jr. is
but all things considered it seems like
a pretty likely way to get Tony back
into the mix a holographic Tony serving
as the onboard AI for a character like
RiRi or Morgan or Rhodey would be a nice
way to bridge the gap to a new Iron Man
or he could even control an empty suit
of armor himself if I am man is going to
come back that there's nothing that says
that he has to be a good guy a new Iron
Man could use Tony's name and technology
for sinister ends that's actually the
premise of one of the most well known
and beloved Ironman stories armor Wars
the premise is that Tony finds out that
his tech has been used by armored
villains like the titanium man
the Crimson Dynamo and even stilt man
and he goes all out to destroy their
armor so that his creations can't be
used for evil the MCU obviously lacks
the sheer number of armored enemies that
are common to built up over the past 60
years but between over Daiya stains
recreation of the armor and Iron Man
Justin hammers mass-produced knockoffs
in Iron Man 2 and all of those pieces of
the armor that were destroyed in Iron
Man 3 there's enough of it out there
that it's not implausible that someone
could build their own especially if they
had an uninterrupted five-year span to
work on it
the idea of pepper and Rhodey teaming up
to save Tony's legacy is compelling and
a villain co-opting Tony's signature
line I am Iron Man
it's almost so easy that is tough to
imagine not doing it plus dealing with
the idea of that legacy these heroes
leave blurring the definitive lines
between heroes and villains that we've
seen in endgame and examining the
Ironman suit as a weapon whose morality
is determined entirely by its user or
that would be an interesting way to move
forward in a world without Tony Stark
one of Marvel's most popular characters
in recent years has been Squirrel Girl
no really she's a star of a long-running
an award-winning comic and she's set to
appear as the lead in an upcoming New
Warriors TV series while agents of
shield and the Netflix Marvel shows a
technically set in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe TV and movie projects have
always been pretty separate if however
the MCU wants to tie things together
there's one way they could generate some
intense brand synergy and recreate an
iconic moment from the comics just have
the new Iron Man be based on the seam or
an evil duplicate of Squirrel Girl
kidnaps Tony Stark and convinces her
rodent Pauwels to crawl into his armor
and scurry around trying to operator
with predictably disastrous results
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]